New York is slowly opening back up for
business the travel ban has been lifted
and public transit is coming back to
life after a winter storm dropped more
than 10 inches here in the city but that
was far less than expected however
Boston New England still being hit
pretty hard ABC correspondent Lana zach
is in Central Park la know what do you
see out there what's it like well it is
definitely chilly out here right now
Stephanie and Alex and that makes me
actually wonder is Eric actually sick or
is he just trying to avoid the freeze
out here at but it was cold we have to
count our blessings yes yeah we really
do have to count our blessings because
we were anticipating this wicked
blizzard and its really hitting the
people further north much more hard than
it is hitting us here and still even
though they've lifted the travel ban you
can see the street behind me there's one
car and right now normally that would be
full of people you know the governor is
not apologizing for closing down the
streets but he does say that it was
worth it because emergency personnel was
able to get to the places they needed to
get to well then why I costing the city
to have been completely shut down then
why it seems I'm looking at that street
behind you with very few cars on it but
that street doesn't appear to be plowed
do you see many plows around
we've seen clouds throughout the day you
know I think that that it just continues
to get pushed around there's a plow
coming at me right now and it's raised
at the moment so who knows you know
that's somebody who has to be a little
bit more more red in on all the details
about how new york city sanitation
decides to plow its streets because it
does seem strange that they left these
streets open and we've seen clouds go by
but but the plows themselves have been
lifted and there's always just like that
and the subway system for so many
commuters I think we expected that we
wouldn't be able to use the streets but
why wouldn't we be able to use the
subway wasn't the subway originally
designed in case of a blizzard go
underground or more importantly can I
get home to park slope using the subway
in a few hours tell me Lana you'll be
able to use the subway later there may
be delays there's it still takes a long
time to get that all up and running and
you're right that's absolutely
unprecedented for us to close down the
subways not because of flooding like in
the case of superstorm sandy but because
of snow and in fact they had parked
several trains on top of the third rail
trying to keep it warm and insulated
from the snow but i think that there's
going to be a lot of questions that are
going to continue to come out of this
today and let's just be clear i take
subway and step takes calves I take I
take cabs I take Cougars and I couldn't
take anything today there you go i God
for Matt Miller coming to my rescue and
thank you very much for ABC
correspondent line of Zack it's not that
I have an issue with the subway I just
go baby sheep I just record it live here